Well, I'm Jad Aboumrad. This is radio lab.
Our program today is about tying all the different flavors of time in here with
me too, shall we say? Taste those flavors.
Is Robert Krulwich corresponding for ABC News at Nightline? Yeah. Hi Robert.
We've been talking about clocks for the last 20 minutes and if you took all the
clock counting 20 minutes exactly. If you took away all the clocks,
we've been talking about the bird clock and the spice clock and the clock on the
wall and then you had to talk about time without mentioning a clock.
What are we left with? How would you do?
That's actually a pretty tough question. What is climb? Essentially,
I have a neighbor, uh, Brian Green is a bestselling author,
elegant universe fabric of the cosmos.
Most recently professor of math at Columbia, professor of Physics at Columbia,
pretty much does Columbia. I asked him your question. I asked him what his time,
if you, if you really pushed me and said, what is time?
I'd say time is that which allows us to see that something has changed.
When you see the second hand in your clock going around,
it's changing position and that's the simplest version of a change corresponding
to time elapsing.
Okay, Robert,
I'm looking at the clock here on the wall and watching these second hand and
he's changing positions just as he says.
Can I imagine all the clocks in the world agree on what a second is,
but what if we were to take the clocks away? Is there, I mean I would still,
I still in my bones believe that that somewhere there's a clock ticking that
says what a second is the same
in Mars. Yeah, right.
Everybody thinks that because it's so sensible that time is universally the same
for everyone. Now, here's the big secret. Apparently that's not true.
Time is not universal and this is,
Brian is part of Einstein's theory of relativity.
When we move relative to each other,
a very basic lesson of relativity is that our watches will tick off time at
different rates. If you have a good watch,
I don't know what a good watch day is, a donut on one,
but if you had a Rolex watch, I never have owned a watch,
but however you've never owned a walker on to watch.
I never liked the idea of a time piece sort of taking away on my arm.
It really always bothered me. But anyway,
if you had a Rolex and I had a Rolex say and we synchronize them perfectly,
then we move relative to one another and then we rejoin and compare our watches.
They will not agree.
Well, to demonstrate what Brian was talking about,
we are now in the central park.
We've got the area entirely roped off because we are going to demonstrate one of
Einstein's famous thought experiments which suggests that the subject and if you
will, I would be the subject, Chad, by all means, et cetera.
You must take a trip at an extraordinarily high speed that's required here.
So if you could help me by giving me whatever you've got over there. Sure.
A here is a jet pack. Turbocharged Chet van. Put It on back. Yeah.
Okay. Now take these rollerblades. Oh, okay. Yeah. I'll put one right.
One around foot, right foot. And when you left on the left, Jake,
set target speed.
Dial on your jet pack to 669 million miles an hour with a little fast,
hundred and 69 million miles an hour.
What time does your watch say? A five 24 so in his mind we're synchronized now.
Exactly synchronized when it gets a five 25 in three, two, one.
Push the red button, hitting the red button. And
I am [inaudible]. I skipped actually going by on this side. I see.
I love the one coming up over there. Oh,
[inaudible] going by there now by the way,
my watch is absolutely perfectly. I'm having a lovely fire
coming in now. Coming closer,
coming closer and
landed. That was very racing. Now Robert. Yes. Look at your watch.
All right. What time does it say it's his, uh, five 26 what times on your watch?
Five 33 that's a seven minute difference. Is your watch broken? Does mine?
No, no, no, no, no, no. Well, time for you is different than time for me.
You mean literally?
Literally.
It's not that my watch somehow was shucking up and wasn't functioning properly.
No time itself is not some universal concept.
Time is held by the individual, by the Observer.
So that if I am moving relative to you, time for me,
a lapse is at a different rate than it does for you.
So relativity says that time and speed are mysteriously coupled.
So the, when I go fast, my time goes slow,
which explains why are watches don't agree exactly.
So this whole notion that we all have the time kind of applies the same to
everybody on earth and Mars, Jupiter,
the entire cosmos that we can see is totally wrong.
But let me ask you this. When you were rushing through space before,
your time was apparently going slower, but did you feel slower?
If I looked at my watch, everything was perfectly normal to me.
My clock was ticking perfectly normal for me. So it was mine in central park.
So what is [inaudible]
if somehow you could appeared in on me up there in outer space, going real,
real fast,
I would have seemed slower to not only would my watch be ticking slower for you.
Everything about,
I mean [inaudible]
Oh [inaudible].
So what do you do with this information? What do you mean? Well,
physics teaches us that if I'm say running down the street and my time is
ticking infinitesimally slower than
that guy's time over there. Why? Because he's standing still
here and you're running right? But you're in different time capsules kind of.
Apparently so, and I know this is what science tells me, right?
But my common sense tells me that that is completely wrong.
Nothing in my experience tells me this is the case.
This is like one of the great conundrums.
It seems to me that what you learned in science is so different what you feel in
your regular life.
How do you live between those two worlds or what you know and what you feel are
so different? Brian, do you learn to trust your mind over your senses?
Is that what you do? Well,
I learned to trust my senses,
but see them within a much larger framework.
I love to walk down the street and imagine that because I'm walking,
I'm kind of shattering the f the time around me.
I'm causing time to elapse at a different rate than it would if I were standing
still. I love that idea. It's not that I don't trust experience.
You're hitting time square and you're wandering to, you think, oh boy,
I am really changing the universe of all these other people. Well,
I really considered a totally personal, so I'm not changing their tone.
I'm changing. I'm changing the rate at which time elapses for me.
So I have power. So when you run to catch a bus, you think, hey,
I got to get on this bus. Also, I'm slowing down time for myself.
I do sometimes, not always, but it's there. And you know,
when I look at the tabletop, I,
I delight in the fact that I can,
in my mind picture the atoms and molecules and the interactions between them and
the mostly empty space that's in there.
And that when my hand touches the table Top,
I see the electrons in the outer surface of my hand pushing against the
electrons in the outer surface of the table. I'm not really touching the table.
My hand never comes into contact with the table.
What's happening as the electrons are getting really close together and they're
repelling each other.
And I love the fact that I'm in essence deforming the surface of the table by
making my electrons come really close to it. That enriches my experience.
It doesn't do share this with others. Rarely.
Uh,
no. I listening to [inaudible]
public radio [inaudible]
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
We're talking about time today and here with me to help you do that is Robert
Watch ABC News and Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
Blah is my specialty, which is are from Brian Green physicist.
Tell us about a frankly troubling idea that there is no such thing as a standard
time, which I'm still having trouble believing frankly. In any case,
it makes me think of this.
Do you know when you see a tortoise wandering through the garden door and he's
going so slow and then you see a hummingbird whiz by film,
really they're moving in different tempos,
but perhaps they're also experiencing entirely different universes of time.
Do you ever wonder about that? I think everybody wonders that, but of course,
unless you are a hummingbird or a tortoise,
you can never really know whether what's going on in your head is different.
True. But Oliver Sacks, the neurologist we met before,
he found a different tempo,
radically different tempos in human beings. Really a,
he's a neurologist and you worked at a hospital in the Bronx,
still does at Beth Abraham where he once had patients who seem so slow.
They were almost frozen. He told me about one of those patients named Myron v
for long periods of the day. Milan would be apparently emotionless,
although when I looked at him,
I would see his frozen finger in different positions in which his right hand
would be raised.
A lot of these patients would be frozen and odd positions,
which I'm illustrating now, but
poses hand in the air, but just stuck, stuck in stuff.
People would be stuck in audit posers. I,
I thought mound was one of those and I, and I commented on this,
that I had often seen him stuck in these are frozen posers and he got indignant
and said, what do you mean photos and posers? He said,
I was just wiping my nose. And I said, I said, Yo, yeah, joking,
putting me on. And he said, I'm not. And I, and he was,
he was as puzzled by what I said as I was by what he had said.
But then after he had told me this, I thought, well, hell, you know, I'm,
I must watch this and I must record it now. He said he was just what?
He was just wiping his nose as I was just wiping my nose.
Okay. Now that's something that takes me about two seconds. Exactly.
Whereas apparently this movement of the arm, if this is what he was doing,
was taking about two hours.
So I took a series of photographs at intervals of a few minutes,
each of still Myron and his, I'm gently going up,
apparently still mountain. How many photographs?
I had about 20 photographs or so in two hours.
And then I put them together in, uh, in the fall.
And then the whole flip pack, you know, the way one used to do is a kid.
And then when couldn't fact see with us that the 20 or so photos covering two
hours in fact showed the smooth movement to wipe his nose and movement,
which normally takes two seconds. But which in him was taking two hours,
although this left opened the profound parcel of how come he was not only taking
two hours to do so, but didn't realize he was taking two hours to do.
So the movement, which to us was glacially slow,
was not slow to him. It was normal. Did you ever show
Myron the pictures that you had made and didn't, did you say,
so Myron, look at this, it took you two hours to do this. I mean,
if you did that and then what did he say?
Um, uh, he was astonished and that's too mild a word. He was thunderstruck
[inaudible]
wow.
So Myron had no idea that he was experiencing the world slower than the rest of
us.
Not into all of our staple all the pictures into a flip book and go and spit up
time and then Myron can see what it was he was doing. But you know,
does a turtle know that he's processing slowly?
Does a hummingbird know that it's processing fast? I don't. I don't think so.
Huh. But he, in this case,
we now know that this is a human being absorbing and performing a drastically
different tempos from the rest of humanity.
[inaudible]
Oliver has another patient did it, likes to talk about her name is Hester. Why?
Um, Hesta, she would have the opposite of the sledding or glaciation.
She would move with extreme speed and a, this came out very,
very clearly sometimes when I had these students play ball with Hesta.
And does that mean they catch? Yeah, they'll play catch. I'm sorry.
Is that the log word for ball? Bruce?
One of the striking things when people are Parkinsonian is when people may
appear unable to initiate any action they can reciprocate.
And if you suddenly throw a ball to someone of parkinsonism,
even if they appear absolutely frozen, they will catch it.
And often I would demonstrate this to the students.
I would usually have seven or eight students and we would usually sit in a
semicircle around the patient's.
So hesta would be in her chair with a semicircle of students facing her.
And she was,
she was so quick and the ball came back and hit the student on his throwing
hands. Wow. So the guy
throws the bullet Hestia,
she catches the ball and throws it back before he's even put his hand back in
place. Just so how many times faster is Hester moving than the student?
Um, well let me put it in general terms.
Her reaction time is a 10th of a second or less.
And usually the best reaction times have Olympic athletes is about a seventh of
a second. Anyhow, the ball came back very,
very fast and I would say to Hesta, slow down, you're too quick for them.
Why do to count up to 10 pause before you throw the ball back. Count up to 10.
She's still in her very speedy mode. Okay. Okay.
And the ball would come back scarcely slower.
And I would say I asked you to count up to 10 and a voice,
which I really can't imitate, but this is the crushed voice.
The technical term is a Femia better speech. Uh,
and the crushed voice of extreme parkinsonism. She will say,
I di Di di Di Dicon Hopson I can't speak quick enough for that.
And her brain, was she thinking that she was giving normal speech? Yeah,
cause she was no more conscious of her speed than mountain was of his slowness.
[inaudible]
Huh. So Myron has somehow slipped into whale timer,
turtle time because of the disease which sent Hester in the opposite direction
into a kind of hummingbird tempo. Do you think there's a limit to this?
How fast she can go or how slowly they must be like some kind of physical
limits? If she wanted to say 20,000 words in a second,
I could even get her brain to do so. Her mouth wouldn't work that fast.
Her tongue wouldn't work that fast. So there's constraints like gravity, energy,
the nature of your body. So there we are at about the rest of us. Uh,
what kind of range is available to you or I
[inaudible]
I am not sure that such a radical slowing speedings occur in the west of us
except perhaps in very unusual circumstances,
perhaps in sports and perhaps in situations of, of mortal danger.
People who are in the zone,
they may give descriptions of what appears to be a baseball comes towards one at
a hundred miles an hour, but some batters they call it batters. Yeah,
okay. Um, but people at bat, okay.
But people at Bat may say that the board seem to come to them more slowly and
they could see the seams on the ball. [inaudible]
in the zone. Robert, I just so happen to have something here,
which is a perfect illustration of what he's talking about.
[inaudible] except it's not baseball has to do with track tracks. Good.
Here's the short extra.
When I'm up, they call my name, I step up on the runway.
Usually it's just relax.
You are the best plant and I don't think anything else after that.
I want that adrenaline coming when he says when take your mark,
cause I only got 10 seconds at one 90 seconds at that point, you know.
But if this pump and pump and pump and pump and then they say take your mark
when I'm exhausted.
You know once I get numb blocks it's like I don't want to be exhausted.
I want to be on fire at that moon. So I'm like I'm ready. I'm ready.
Tim's just 52 degrees,
50 degrees out here and bod is warmed up sitting in the blahs and like the colon
, even in any phrasing, me don't,
I don't even feel no cold cause I got so much adrenaline going through my body.
I'm just ready to put it to him today. Put everybody
and if you're not ready,
it doesn't matter at this point because you have to be ready.
And when he says set,
sit sitting that gun and go out leaving all you got,
you just, just take it off. [inaudible] you go feel the strength that day.
Go slow down, no fatigue, and Nanga will up whoever's in lanes behind me.
They go get it. I'm just listening. Get in tune, get in tune,
listen to the whole hustle. The crowd is the g choir for the gun.
In that moment when they say, take your mark set, I become the gun.
So when that gun fires,
it's almost like I'm the bullet being fired out of the pistol.
And that's my reaction. When I hear that sound,
it's almost like there's a firing pin smacking me in my butt and pushing me.
So it's not that I sound out everything around me.
I've already sounded out everything because I'm the bullet and it's only me in
the chamber in lineup, we hear the and say fit.
And at that point you become blind and deaf because you don't,
you don't go off of what you think you've heard because if you do that,
you just lost the race. You have to be one with the gun.
And when he says set, Eh,
I just breathe all the air in a deep inhale,
take your last look on the competitors in the lane. Now focused. Just thinking,
driving, go, driving, go and then I hold my breath and then
[inaudible] I let up all the air out and that's when I start running as fast as
I can.
When you're running and you're so relaxed in what you do
to where a song can just pop into your mind about 30 meters,
that is the ultimate point I think an athlete wants to be cause that's when you
get that peak performance.
It's almost like everything is moving in slow motion and you watching the birds
kind of slowly fly by and you hear that song just with them.
In a year when I take off and I start to climb in the air,
it all goes pretty fast.
But once I hit that apex of the jump and my hips are up over the bar,
time really slows down.
I mean you can just feel this rotation and it feels like someone's grabbed a
hold of your hips and really giving you a push,
a boost up in the air and for this moment that you're sort of suspended on top
of the bar. It's really serene. It's really almost peaceful.
It just seems like it lasts an eternity.
Come off the turn. I'm in the front. I'm in the front and who they coming from?
[inaudible] I'm in the front so I'm just thinking, just get away. Just get away.
Just get away. Tone out the bro. Hold on, hold on. The stretch it out.
Start getting to the top of Cortona after birth total. Hold on.
See you've come up the side, you have to lift. You gotta hold on.
Stall is happening. Trying to get that. The can just fight him off.
You be flying them all at the end. It's just compete,
compete, compete and then Leah to take
them all. Fuck the Mosley. You cut them off.
[inaudible] that's kind of stuff I live for.
I live for those intense moments like there again,
it's hard to excel the fence. Sometimes they too are human,
but it's true.
And I've had a heart surgery in year 2000 but as athletes,
and you can ask almost any athlete,
they'll tell you we believe we invest because if we go in there with any other
thoughts, there's no chance of us not though, because we have to believe.
We have to confuse ourselves into believing that no matter what's wrong with you
or what you're dealing with,
it's not going to be a factor to what you're trying to accomplish.
We believe we invisible
thanks to the next big thing and sound artists.
Ben Ruben for that a piece he produced for the national track and Field Hall of
fame, you can visit them on the web@trackhall.com so Robert,
what do you think this was a case?
I think of athletes showing you how we contest with time get power by mastering
time shaving. It's slightly time and power. Have a long history.
That's what we'll look at shortly. I'm jacked up on Ron [inaudible].
Now back in a moment, you're the same.
You're the same to radio lab.